hey this is really funny we've been
talking more and more about the idea of
taxing the rich and part of the reason
why we've been talking about that is
that more and more elected officials in
Congress are floating ideas like that of
Alexandria acasio Cortez to have a much
higher top marginal tax rate on people
earning a lot of money maybe that starts
at 2 million 5 million 10 million we
don't know could do it a lot of
different ways but generally the
questions around this issue are what
should the top tax rate be how much
income should put you into that top tax
rate is the economy better off by taxing
the rich or by giving the rich tax cuts
these are the sorts of questions that
are being asked now and as far as public
opinion goes the country is basically in
favor of taxing the very rich to reduce
income inequality and to pay for
programs that would help Society yeah if
you are rich you're more likely to be
against taxing the rich more with the
exception of some billionaires who say I
would pay more but we should be paying
more because society needs it but
overall taxing the very rich at a higher
rate pulls very very well even Fox News
polls show this to be the case and I
have a clip I'm going to play for you of
Fox News hosts being visibly shocked by
this and it's hilarious listen to what
they call by the way the idea of taxing
the rich in a more fair way and pay
special attention to the indignation and
the shock that you'll hear in their
voices
there isn't a seat what seems to be a
movement against capitalism in this
country this is a piece of in Politico
just published soak the rich Americans
say go for it in this piece it talks
about how recent polling is showing that
the American public is increasingly on
board with raising taxes on the rich as
evident evidence we've pulled up this
latest Fox News poll on the issue
whether Americans support raising taxes
on the wealthy on incomes over 10
million bucks those that are in favor of
that 70 percent Charles over a million
dollars in income 65%
are in favor of raising taxes the idea
of fairness has been promoted in our
schools for a long time and we're
starting to see kids who grew up in this
notion that fairness above all and and
now they're becoming voting age and
they're bringing this ideology with them
yeah it's shocking why would the 99.5%
want more taxes on the top not 1% but
0.5% or 0.2% as we are talking about
when you're talking about taxing people
making more than 10 million dollars oh
right because it makes economic sense
and they said during the segment this
seems to be a movement against
capitalism they don't even understand
what capitalism is because if you're
talking about a 70% marginal tax rate on
people making more than 10 million
dollars it's not socialism that got them
the 10 million dollars right in in
socialism when someone gets 10 million
dollars they are the authoritarian
dictators that are in charge but if
you're talking about a tax rate on
people making over 10 million that's
something you only even really discuss
in a capitalist society that can only
happen in a capitalist system that
allows that to happen to begin with and
then Charles Payne talks about fairness
we don't have equality of opportunity
period in this country and Charles Payne
tries to frame it as these deluded kids
who have been brainwashed into wanting
fairness above all else no one's calling
for fairness as a quality of outcome
right fairness as equality of outcome
meaning no matter what your skills are
no matter what choices you make in life
no matter what you end up with the same
in terms of income and net worth as
everybody else right that wouldn't be
capitalism we have a capitalist system
and what fairness means in a capitalist
system is that we do everything possible
to get everybody ideally as close as
possible to equality of opportunity in
social democracy that's exactly what it
is that we're pushing for it's
capitalism with safeguards and social
welfare with a focus
on making sure no one falls too far and
also on making sure that at the very
very top you don't start to have this
absolutely deluded separation from what
makes sense in the context of the
economy so it's perfectly fine for
people to have more than ten million
dollars in income in this more fair
society that the country seems to be in
favor of but you're just going to have
to pay your fair share and pay a little
bit more and when you hear the disdain
in their voices as they look at these
poll results and realize kids have a
concept of what's fair how disgusting
those kids thinking about a more fair
economy and a more fair society shame on
them this is the attitude and they can't
really do anything about the fact that
yes even a Fox News poll shows that when
you say should people making over a
million a year pay a little more most
people say the answer is yes should
people making over ten million dollars a
year pay a little more even more people
say the answer is yes and they just
can't seem to handle that over at Fox
News send me your thoughts about this
i'm on instagram at david pakman the
show is on instagram at david pakman
show we will take a quick break and be
back with so much more right after this
one of today's sponsors is privacy comm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from
Vinnie's being hacked which we've been
talking about for a while on the program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial somewhere if you don't want your
real credit card number to be exposed
and on file and their app and browser
extension let you autofill the virtual
credit card number into the credit card
field when you're buying things online
there are a ton of different advantages
to shopping and paying bills with a
system like this everything is totally
secure and encrypted and in some
situations you can earn 5% cash back on
your purchases it's all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time everybody in our audience
who signs up gets $5.00 towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link below